[Music]
so yeah I'm Edie I'm head of data
science earth red so just a little bit
first of all about what thread is we're
an online personal styling service
currently men only I'm afraid you sign
up and you get a signed er stylist for
free and you receive some
recommendations that we send out and in
emails at each week you can also browse
our catalog everything sort of
personalized to you and you can recon 10
this personalized to you and of course
you can buy some clothes through our
site if you want to we're a small
start-up currently getting there near 5
years old now but we're rapidly growing
so just to give you a little sort of
tour of the thread site this is once
you've signed up this is sort of your
your home feed where you receive all
your kind of recommended content so
might be might be an outfit suggestion
of what to wear might be particular
items that we think would be really
great for you so your stylist will will
will recommend you these these selection
of outfits each week as you can see I
take the suggestions very literally so
this is not just a great weekend outfit
but a great outfit to wear to PI data
and I dress exactly how my stylist tells
me to dress and we also have an area of
the site which is all about sort of
personalized content for you so it might
be you know we think of particular sort
of set of shoes would be great for you
or we make suggestions of how you how
you might dress it for different kind of
occasions that type of thing and we also
have more closer to a traditional
e-commerce part of the site where you
can just browse freely browse all the
items that we we sell through the sites
but it's it's all sort of personalized
and curated
you so you don't have thousands upon
thousands of items to control through
and everything's ranked in a
personalized way so where does the data
science machine learning come in well we
have about half a million clients to
style but we're a small start-up and
we've got eight stylists who work for us
so how can we sort of scale the work of
eight stylist to style half a million
clients well that's where sort of
machine learning algorithms we is sort
of interweave everywhere in the site and
so it's a combination of of of
algorithms with stylists generated
content and that we that we link
together which makes it really
interesting interesting problem so this
is just a picture of team threads at
least as it existed it's probably about
a year ago now so we're now a bit bigger
than this but just to give you sort of
an idea of of how many people we are ok
so this talk is going to be a talk of
two parts the first part I'm going to
just talk about a really simple
off-the-shelf technique which you which
I tried in sort of half an hour and
worked incredibly well on on part of our
data in the second part I'm just going
to talk about a very similar technique
which you might have expected to work
well but didn't and talk a bit more
about sort of lessons learned in in the
era of recommender engines so and my
other reason for giving this first by
the talk on style components is I can
just show some lots of pretty pictures
so question of style now getting a
user's style and getting their sort of
taste right has been one of the hardest
things that we've faced at thread and
the reason for this is that the
vocabulary of style is complicated it
doesn't really mean the same for any two
individuals so for example if I asked
you how would you describe your style
there are all sorts of words that you
might use
classic preppy casual smart or on a
street hipster cool smart but what do
any of these words really mean
and actually when thread started I think
we before my time but we we did actually
try to ask users how would they describe
their style and our stylists found that
that men just just couldn't really tell
us what the style was and if they did
tell us the stylist would look at the
kind of items they were buying or wanted
to buy and they just completely disagree
with them so they might say no I'm
definitely not preppy and then the
stylist to say yeah you are actually so
it really doesn't work very well and it
was it was very hard for our stylist to
get a handle on what people meant and so
they couldn't recommend a very very good
very good outfits so we quickly realized
that it's much better to do this thing
visually and just sort of ask users when
they sign up to just just pick some some
images that they that they like of
people dressed in various outfits pick
some images that sort of that they would
quite like to wear perhaps or although
they would like to sort of aspire to
dress like but of course when you do
this you do need a lot of a lot of
photos to kind of cover all the sort of
nuances and tastes of different styles
so you end up with with quite a lot of
quite a lot of data to analyze about a
given user and whilst having all this
sort of detailed data of exactly sort of
which kind of styles and outfits and
individual user whilst that is very
useful for for us to make good
recommendations we thought it would be
nice to get be able to get a bit of a
kind of summary view of what a user
style what users stolid and and what our
sort of population of users stover so
first we need to kind of translate from
this world of style and fashion which
obviously as a data science I find hard
to understand in
is something that is a little easier for
a data scientist to understand which is
a style vector which is just a vector of
ones and zeros a sparse vector of ones
and zeros know that this is getting a
bit easier now right so and yeah and and
and even better now we look at the
population of users and we look at all
those vectors of ones and zeros that
they've chosen and we have a we have a
side price sparse matrix which which is
much much better for a data scientist to
understand so we're in the world with
sparse binary matrices and kind of a
natural thing to try to do if you're a
data scientist you just want to see how
this data looks is to see if we can do
some dimensionality reduction in this in
this in this big matrix of our users in
the Style photos that they've chosen so
I just chose to use a standard
off-the-shelf technique you can do this
you know in psychic learning in 10 15
minutes non-negative matrix
factorization yn MF well I thought that
first of all that we have positive data
here we have ones and zeros but also I
didn't really want sort of negative
styles coming up so I didn't
particularly would it be useful to say
you're a negative hipster for example
well yeah maybe maybe it would actually
so so yes so I chose this method very
simple off-the-shelf method and it just
works amazingly well here so what do we
get out of this well we we get a you
can't see this yeah we get a we get a
style component matrix which is sort of
like the lower dimensional directions in
style space if you like and we get a
nice kind of use a small reduced
dimensional vector which we could call
user style profile so what happens if we
actually zoom in excuse my fancy slide
transitions have got a bit carried away
here what let's let's have a look at
what comes out if we if we look at the
style component matrix in close up and
here's here's what you get so
sort of showing part of the matrix here
and don't worry you can't see this
- well yaks are showing a bit more
detail they're just just showing sort of
part of the matrix here not a lot
although sort of components that we end
up using but what you see is it just
really nicely separates out all of the
suits in one component it just says okay
that's purple all the suit guys together
in one in one component we've got a much
much more kind of casual street sort of
components we have a slightly kind of
preppy component there and and and it
just sort of came out just really nice
and I was quite amazing I saw this how
how easily this sort of decomposed into
some nice kind of coherent components so
what was nice about this is that well
why do this in the first place well it
kind of provided a coherent sort of
language that we could use internally to
describe users because remember we're
working here with sort of machine
learning but with humans in the loop so
we've got we've got real stylists
experts and we've got data scientists
working together we want to be able to
kind of talk about users in a coherent
way so this was sort of very useful for
that and even areas of the company like
marketing to be able to better
understand the groups of our users we
can kind of use this as a as a technique
to kind of group users or cluster users
according to their according to their
style which is really important when we
use marketing which is so heavily image
based we can look at the demographics
associated with each with each component
again something their marketing are
really really interested in who should
they market two to maybe get users who
have higher budgets for example and at
the age of the users associated with
these things and of course we can use
this inside inside recommender engines
as model features and so on but that
probably wasn't the primary purpose for
us for us trying this so our stylist
actually started labeling these kind of
informally slightly jokey labeling these
these components so these ones the city
boys which which I'm quoting from our
head stylist shown here Classic suits
business looks mostly safe
with a few role next worn under suits as
the most daring and these users tend to
be not surprisingly high budget users
and their slightly older user so that
you know fairly obvious but it's kind of
nice to be I'd actually kind of quantify
exactly what that means and this this
components which are stylists called the
dude next door
he's like a sort of basic casual user
and he has simple separates that don't
make a statement
no not slim sitting reliable menswear go
two's eg polos and these users have very
low budgets um they've almost sort of
like maxed out their when we sign up we
are from what their budget self
different categories and they sort so
not maxed out they've they've min doubt
the budget sliders all the way to the
left of these users and interesting
they're actually a slightly older user
this one called tailored smart casual
Blazers with jeans and no fuss and they
have higher budgets and under slightly
older user and this one which I start is
called scanned Ian slim scan D
contemporary streamlined overcoats with
crew necks and slim jeans so and they
had they have actually low but fairly
low budgets and a younger user so yeah
it's been really kind of interesting
just to look at this a very very simple
technique that kind of works works
really well and it lets us get a nice
easily understandable kind of start
simple style profile low dimensional
style profile for our users so for
example my style profile profile here
indicating that at least when I signed
up to thread I had no idea how to dress
obviously I can't quite decide sort of
where I see it right hence why my
stylist is helping me out so just you
know you can get a kind of like a nice
sort of distribution over over the
different style components here so these
are just picking out a few examples what
one thing is definitely clear that I was
not going to be into biker jackets which
is component number six it
so so yeah I want to show there's a nice
little visual example of a sort of
interesting collaboration between data
science and human experts something that
as I said was just taking a really
really simple off-the-shelf technique
and just just happen to work very well
on this on this data so on to part two a
little bit different here I'm going to
talk about some of the lessons that
we've learned thread about some aspects
of building recommended recommender
engines and the kind of link to the
first part of the talk here is that well
one of obviously one of the main
techniques in in recommender engines is
collaborative filtering and in
particular user item based collaborative
filtering where Trident trusted
techniques are exactly the kind of
matrix factorization that I showed you
in the first half of the talk so lots of
people use matrix factorization based
collaborative filtering to do
recommender engines but for us we did
try this along amongst many approaches
and for us they really don't work very
well at all so I kind of spent a bit of
time kind of analyzing why why that is
and I think it sort of boils down to a
few a few key points firstly this past
sparsity of rating data per user per
item
we do have lot of new users they haven't
rated many things and also we're
constantly getting new stock all the
time from from our from our brands and
third-party suppliers so there's that
constant churn and rotation which means
that the the number of items sort of
rated present and remember rated for
items fairly low that definitely doesn't
doesn't help this type of method at
least at least out of the box off the
shelf
we do have already very rich metadata
about both users and items and partly
because we when we ask people to sign up
to the surface service we do collect a
lot of user data up front so we perhaps
are more user data than most standard
recommender engine systems would have
and also item data as well for the for
this whole system to work we need a lot
of tagged data associated with the items
which we have available for the whole of
the website to work really so it's sort
of not extra for us to go go away and
collect that item metadata it's already
there
so those do step through those things
already are kind of biasing us towards a
model which is much more of a
content-based recommender rather than
collaborative filtering based
recommender the other thing is that if
you actually analyze what happens if you
try a matrix factorization type approach
on this data user item rating data it's
pretty obvious what the kind of
principle kind of components are picking
up from the data and there are two main
components which are pretty obvious and
very easily captured by a couple of
simple feature couple of simple features
so there's there's the there's a
component related to price it turns out
that people like cheap things
so-so so there's a very dominant factor
related to price which which comes out
of of a matrix factorization but you can
very simply hand engineer a a model a
very simple model feature that will will
beat that will easily sort of beat that
the second kind of principal component
is it's obviously correlated to you as
well as just is obviously the overall
sort of the overall passed rating
history for a particular item so a
global a global rating rather than a
personalized one and again that's that's
something that's sort of trivial to
capture in a more traditional model
feature if you are using a more
traditional type of
standard classifier or or regressor so
yeah as I said a more traditional sort
of hybrid based or content-based model
can can learn those with with sort of a
few simple features you do get more
success by kind of aggregating data
higher up a hierarchy or focusing on
sort of users who are rating items very
some prolific prolifically so it's it's
not that we haven't had some success
with with collaborative filtering here
but it's it's it's much it's much harder
than than in the first example I gave
you we're just sort of came out really
nicely straight away so I didn't really
want to go into sort of too much detail
on on the ins and outs in the model but
basically we are using a hybrid
recommender model which is a classifier
or or aggressor it's trying to predict
things like ratings or orders sales and
it's using user features user user
features item features and user cross
item features and of course this kind of
model is is nice because that it's first
of all it's very sort of simple to train
in terms of just using kind of
traditional content-based features based
on any of the tags we have the user data
we have etc and if you want to put in
features which are based on
collaborative filtering you can do that
you can put them in as as user cross
item features either by kind of pre
computing user user embeddings and item
embeddings first as part of a pipeline
and then feeding them in a separate
features or you can try and learn the
whole system end-to-end but I'm not
convinced as a huge advantage in in in
doing that or at least I've not found
that so far there's one area of model
feature where we've we've had quite
quite a quite a bit of success with
which are real time user events based
model features
and obviously this you can't use these
everywhere they're only relevant for
sort of a part of the site which is very
reactive and where you're able for a
given user to sort of re let's say re
rank items quickly after the user is
maybe making some activity on the site
so the type of thing I'm talking about
just sort of you can see illustrating
the picture is just you know if a user
is clicking on an item liking an item
maybe sort of clicking through on to an
item page and clicking onto some similar
items all these kind of implicit
feedback signals that you can get out of
user event data of what users are
actually doing on the site maybe even
scrolling behavior what they're
scrolling past you can derive some quite
powerful features that have a lot of
predictive power over a short time scale
so you know if someone is is clicking on
a lot of particular kind of jumpers then
it's it's a quite a good indication that
they're sort of currently interested in
that in that particular category of item
that was just one one example but I
wanted to talk briefly about the
challenges of building a real-time
training pipeline because this is where
where things can get really tricky and
this is very related to Stephens talk
that he gave a little earlier on he
talked about some similar issues
especially when you're when you're
training models which have this sort of
time-sensitive nature to them so I've
faced this kind of problem in a few jobs
that I've had and amazingly I think it's
amazing that there isn't a sort of
off-the-shelf solution for for for this
type of training framework feature
training framework and we've always sort
of had to end up we've always ended up
writing our own in some form so this
time so it's read I I wanted to try to
do this sort of rights from the start
because they'd had some experience of
this these things going wrong in the
past and so I kind of gave a set of a
wish list for a real time feature
pipeline to to our data engineer and
we're working in a small team sort of
just meet me in him and and and so I
wanted to sort of present a little bit
of kind of what was on my wish list and
talk about why why I think that they're
important so the first one is something
that the Steven mentioned in his talk
which is that you should try to make
sure that all significant logic which
you're using in feature in constructing
features so that maybe things like data
transforms aggregates that type of thing
should be on a shared code path between
your live serving
system online and your offline training
I've seen cases where this has gone
wrong subtly in the past and it's it's
always very very hard to diagnose where
the problem is and an example from a
previous job was in ad tech was where we
had a model training model trained which
was a Python separate model training
pipeline and as part of that we were
taking a URL string and we were
splitting the URL into the different
sort of top-level domain and sub sub
domains below and there were a bunch of
sort of special cases with this sort of
Eurorail splitting so it wasn't
completely a completely simple obvious
kind of function but but in that tech
stack the online model that the the
actually served the serve the
recommendations because it was ad tech
it was very latency sensitive so that
was riff that was rewritten in I think
it was in Java and so it was that part
was completely rewritten the URL would
come in live from the stream and it
would be split but that was a Java
function that was doing that splitting
and the reunit tests on on both these
functions set for
the same unit test but still there was a
very very subtle difference in how the
splitting worked and when you have
something which when you have model
features that are trained you know the
coefficients are learnt and conditioned
on something being a feature being
transformed in the imprecise way you can
get completely completely different
results online obviously even with a
small subtle bug and the only kind of
way that you learn about that and can
detect that is if you're actually
tracking a live model performance metric
like if you're able to track live AEC
from the actual live serve results and
not test at a UC but live a UC and you
notice that you're live a live a model a
UC of your classifier is way worse than
your test set a you see that you've got
out of your model training pipeline when
you see that what what do you do it's
it's it's very hard to sort of pin down
what where is that AUC difference coming
from like oh I thought we should have
should have had a point eight a UC but
what I'm actually seeing is point seven
why do I have that huge difference and
we spent ages trying to track down that
one and it turned out to be a tiny tiny
bug in a in a URL splitting splitting
function so ever since then I kind of
had this this this this idea that it's
really important to try to share code
between online and offline it sometimes
with in latency sensitive applications
it's hard to achieve that but I think
you should try and make every effort to
achieve that if you can second item on
the wish list was it must be possible to
painlessly reconstruct the state of user
feature data at arbitrary points back in
time and this this is where these kind
of like time time-sensitive real time
features this is particularly important
in this err in this area because because
of the old accidental peeking into the
future problem and accidentally kind of
using user events from the future where
you shouldn't be during during training
normally in machine learning you know
maybe a few a few you could perhaps get
away with that sometimes without hurting
you too much but with these kind of
real-time features it can really bite
you if you get this wrong a relevant
example in our case would be it turns
out suppose we're trying to predict the
likelihood that someone will make a
purchase of an item and we're trying to
use all the all of the user events up to
the current state of time to make that
prediction of whether they're likely to
predict to buy an item it turns out that
a lot of users will will will like items
that they rate the items that they've
bought but but they like them after they
bought them so they'll buy something and
but then they think oh I probably should
have rated then I'll give that a heart
so imagine you've got an accidental bug
here where you're accidentally using the
fact that user has liked an item to
predict whether they're going to buy it
and you're using the fact they've liked
an item from the future and obviously
you're going to learn a really really
strong model coefficient is going to
latch onto that and it's going to love
to these going to love seeing that so
it's that type of it's that type of
problem that you have to be really
careful to guard against and to do that
if you if you're doing this kind of
real-time feature training you need to
be able to go back and kind of replay
history faithfully so what was the state
of this uses users user data you know
last week so obviously there's kind of
an obvious way to do that is you just
got the sort of raw user event logs and
you go back to the raw user event logs
and you and you may be kind of replay
them up to a certain point in time
that's an easy way you can ensure that
you can do that but often that's going
to be really slow to do that right so
it's it's going back to sort of raw user
events and sort of replaying them every
time you want to do a new model training
can be pretty painful
so the third wishlist is kind of
necessary for a real time a feature
pipeline because it needs to be real
time so you need to actually have the
user data available for you to use to to
make recommendations in real time so it
needs you need to be at a query for
up-to-date user data and where this is
kind of non non-obvious is if you are if
you're making sort of derived features
say little aggregates based on based on
user event data for example a sort of a
histogram over the categories of items
that a user has been clicking on
something like that you probably want
that stored in a form where you can
easily kind of retrieve it in that in
that aggregated form rather than just
get receiving the R or events and the
final one is that it should be easy to
experiment with new features derived
from these Rorie's or events because
there is kind of one obvious solution
for the first one - that sort of
satisfies the first three on the
wishlist which is that you have the user
the ROI events you have maybe these
aggregates which you're storing to serve
online which is something like say a
just a histogram over the over
categories of items that the user has
been clicking on that could be one
aggregate you could store in a in a
compressed form to just pick up online
so one thing you could do is you could
just you could just sort of snapshot and
cache to a kind of a history of these
aggregates as they change over time over
history and during model training you
could go and look up oh what was this
what was this category distribution last
week for this user I could just go and
retrieve that if I've been writing it
out but the problem with that is that
it's that's fine for one particular
feature that you've made and is working
and is live in the model and that that
works fine but what happens if you want
them to change the way that they change
this aggregate in somewhere you sort of
got to go and redo that the whole thing
if you want to come up with a new
feature based on the raw events so it's
quite surprisingly hard to sort of
fulfill all of these things
at once and we we had a look into this
as a team as I said and we didn't find
any kind of reasonable off-the-shelf
solutions for this so James Harlow who's
pictured here he he's our data engineer
and he went away and scratched his head
and came up with a design that is that
she's actually working working really
well that we just put together from
various kind of components so just
describing this at a very high level so
I don't know too much time we've got a
we've got a raw JSON
Vence aggregator which is which is
fluent D and they get separated into two
streams one is we're just using Amazon
Kinesis for this because it's easier to
use a managed service for the so that
the online the online path is sort of on
the left and green and the offline path
for training is on the right in red
we're store to storing the world events
on s3 so that's sort of fairly standard
but the first bit the nice bit I think
that achieves 0.1 in the wish list which
is that you should share code everywhere
you can is that we've got spark we've
got a spark streaming job that is
constructing live real-time user
aggregates just Verte these very simple
things like window functions histograms
of user event per user and and that's
doing this live in a streaming manner
and then we've got offline the same code
same spark code working offline to
construct the same aggregates from the
roar event logs if we want to replay
offline through through the whole of
history so that's nice because that's
got some shared code then we've got a
live user feature data cache which I'd
sort of said you know you kind of want a
few latency sensitive we're just using
Redis but it could be any kind of key
value store you could use for this and
then we've got a historical user feature
aggregates cached on s3 for a particular
feature so we've got this sort of like
history of these aggregates for a
particular feature kind of cached on s3
that we can just go and retrieve and
then finally for serving live serving we
have just shared Python
that constructs a feature from the user
data live in the recommendation server
online but the same Python code exact
same Python code offline when we run
model training is used to pull from
these historical user feature aggregates
on on s3 so it kind of pretty much
achieves to wish this so and is working
quite nicely so I just wanted to sort of
show that how the high-level I'm kind
kind of out of time I think aren't I so
I'll have to shame because I have to
leave this one the plants effects for
you to ask about two minutes okay all
right this is this is just a funny kind
of little lesson learned from what can
happen in in with the wall can easily
happen when you construct training data
if you're not careful about little
biases in the way you're collecting the
data so what happens is if you if you
build a little model that's say for
example trying to predict the
probability of the user ordering an item
after they've seen it somewhere on the
site what you'll find is that pants have
a very high order probability and but
this doesn't really mean that you you
want to be necessarily recommending
pants to the user all the time and where
this we this was a sort of bug that we
had to track down or not really a bug
but a training set construction bias in
the end and it kind of comes from the
fact that we were just collecting
training data from all across the site
and we weren't sort of caring too much
about where it came from if you use a
seasoned item somewhere on the site we
count it as a training data point but
not all those points are equal because
people operate in different modes on
different parts of the sites when
they're actually going and looking for
underwear they are not so picky about
their pants right they they'll maybe
view a few items but you know if they're
British its Marks and Spencer they'd
probably just buy it it's a multi pack
so and users love multi packs so they're
probably just just buy that so they're
not nearly as picky they don't scroll
through endless amounts of items looking
for it so therefore there ends up with a
high order probability if you just sort
of ignore that training set construction
kind of bias in your data the way you've
collected your data so we had to do some
stuff to control
that I just thought it was kind of
amusing example so yeah and yes thank
you
um yeah I just want to say that and
we're also looking to expand our team so
if you like this kind of area like to
work with me in detail then on this
stuff then come trust me afterwards any
questions yeah hello um thanks for that
that was really great could you comment
a bit on the how the interaction between
the stylists like how do this dye lists
use your so there's some sort of live
recommendations there on the site but
what interaction work between what they
come up with and what you do yeah
the stylists are basically coming up
with sort of candidates if you like that
they're curating their curating outfits
and their and Anna curating sort of
items that they really like for
different kind of sets of users that's
that that kind of thing and then because
obviously there's no way that a
individual stylist can sort of send out
recommendations manually to hundreds of
thousands of users then that's sort of
where the machine machine learning model
comes in and will rank rank items and
obviously when you browse the site live
then that's machine learning model which
is which is ranking the items for you
live so that's sort of roughly how it
how it fits together yes
thank you I've got a question about how
you measure the success of what you
doing like how you measure the success
of your models people all the things but
they may might return all the stuff that
they ordered so do you check order to
check actual sales like what they keep
yeah we we are sort of measuring a
combination of performance metrics
related to the models obviously sort of
whether we sell stuff is important for
us but that's not the primary kind of
metric that we're trying to drive drive
up because we are we're are sort of a
styling and recommendation service so
the customer satisfaction with the
recommendations that they're receiving
is sort of the kind of primary metric
that we're tracking so we do we track
that through various ways so you can own
your home feed you can you can sort of
rate say their outfit that we recommend
as a whole and we use that rating data
as a sort of metric for the main kind of
recommendations or how we're doing there
and also user user surveys and direct
kind of user feedback as well yeah do
you have any Glenn store for your
service for women and yes we do intend
to I just don't be any more specific on
the time line not immediately I think
we're we're like we are expanding and we
are likely to first sort of expand
internationally before we do women's
service but we definitely want to do
it's just we're sort of too small to
have the kind of resources to do that
right now
yeah hi thanks for the talk I was just
wondering how do you deal with a
seasonality in taste I would imagine
that people perhaps would be more
interesting in buying suits during
winter times but in order summer
vacation they may be more like
b-style I don't know if this exists and
if so how does the model cope with that
yeah we we do have some seasonal
features which we learn in the model
fairly simple things but it's it's it's
quite hard it's an area where it's an
area where that that's that's part of
the sort of service which is more kind
of curated by the stylist so they'll
they'll sort of say what type of outfit
is appropriate for winter versus kind of
summer when when they're sort of putting
together the outfit and that from the
kind of candidate set that we use so
it's not so much part of the model as
being something which is sort of
manually created yeah okay that you
mentioned the need to have a kind of
time machine capability when you're TRAI
to stop learning model peeking into the
future
yeah and you said that that was a quite
a painful thing to do and do you
actually do it and how yeah yes so
that's kind of so I just kind of go back
to the slide so so this this solution
that we came up with here when we do
model training we're kind of looking
back by retrieving these historical user
feature aggregates that that's where
we've got this sort of time history
where we do go back in time when we
construct training data when we've got
training labels which were which are a
time series of training labels and we're
matching those up against aggregates so
we're always calling sort of calling
into that time machine and asking for
for any given for any given training
data instance we're asking for what the
state of this particular user feature at
this moment in time what was it then
that's what we do when we when we
construct raining data for features for
offline training yeah
okay if there are no more questions and
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]